I'm not going to spend a ton of time on
this but there has been this viral
moment yesterday when President Joe
Biden flew down to Florida to survey the
damage and to make some announcements
alongside Republican Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis where Biden dropped an
F-bomb and said no one F's with a Biden
and of course a bunch of Republicans are
like oh this isn't presidential this
isn't the right tone to be striking
Huffington Post article uh president on
hot Mike with Florida official no one
efts with a Biden he made the comment
during what looked like a laid-back
exchange with Fort Myers beaches mayor
while touring the area damaged by
Hurricane Ian
Biden was recorded uh one of the this
was one of the areas hit by the
hurricane Murphy can be heard Ray
Murphy's the mayor of Fort Myers Beach
Murphy can be heard thanking Biden for
coming to the state before both
officials exchanged the phrase keep the
faith and then Biden told Murphy no one
efts with a Biden so let's take a look
at the clip and we do have to bleep it
because we're on radio and television
and we don't want any FCC problems for
our stations but if you want the
unedited version it's easy to find
out
[Music]
that's exactly right that's exactly
right all right good to see you
thank you guys all right so a bunch of
right Wingers oh this isn't presidential
this isn't how a president should speak
imagine thinking this is a problem so
first of all
first of all
this actually is the real Biden right
remember the classic when President
Biden was vice president and they signed
Obamacare and Biden was on a hot mic
telling Barack Obama this is a big
effing deal he's just enthused
enthusiastic in that way it's the real
Biden which I appreciate there was the
Peter Ducey SOB hot mic incident
[Music]
that's a great asset more inflation
what a stupid son of a [ __ ] okay and so
you know all the right Wingers have to
do their dog and pony show about its
Unbecoming of a president and all this
stuff if your belief was that one of the
great things about Trump was that he
talked like a so-called normal person
and he told it like it is and he said
what's on his mind and you don't have
some fake reverence for elite media
people and all of that stuff and it's
good when Trump does it how can we
possibly believe you're really upset at
Biden dropping an F-bomb give me a break
guys it is so pathetic and contrived
that we shouldn't even really give it
attention and so I'm not gonna spend
more than the two minutes on it that I
already have this is Joe Biden this is
one of the things I actually like about
Joe Biden in the context of lots of
things I don't like so much it is
absolutely plausible that these right
Wingers are actually upset about this in
this way and if they are they're
complete and total Hypocrites let's take
a quick break and we'll be back right
after this
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David packman show by
getting your next mattress from Helix
sleep and and you'll get up to 350 off
any mattress plus two free pillows when
you go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman
the link is down below